today's pick for the little yellow book
is one for anyone who likes to keep
their hands clean as well as their
conscience
it's blue lands mickey and friends hand
soap kit it's an 18 investment but
here's what you get
um a glass bottle that you permanently
keep and then you get the little refills
and what i love about this is i'm a big
blue land fan they're one of my favorite
environmentally conscientious brands
but this is a great way to get your kids
thinking in the right direction so this
is a great
time
to get your kids started on
planet saving tips so this is planet
saving because you're making in a glass
jar you keep you're not throwing away
the plastic
soap container right i am so awake when
it comes to plastic and trying to find
the alternatives because i want there to
be a planet for my kids and i think this
is just a great optimistic fun way to do
it and if you go to the blue land
website you'll also find heaps of just
the most amazing products they are truly
one of my favorite companies and um i
think now we get our kids started on the
right track which feels really good and
by the way good for you blue land
getting a collab with disney nice
[Laughter]
yeah so thank you so much for joining us
you guys today it has been such a
pleasure and a privilege to hang out
with you
and for anyone who may be watching at
home or on the go please take this
energy with you
we hope that you have a fantastic day
and just
yeah have a good one
[Music]